de regreso al territorio francés pese a
la decepción kilian mbappé y al resto
del equipo se trasladaron desde el
Aeropuerto al centro de París para
compartir con sus fanáticos
aparecieron en el balcón del hotel
cririllón con vistas a la Plaza de la
Concordia donde se les rindió una
calurosa bienvenida
solo Mira la atmósfera estamos todos
aquí juntos estamos muy contentos de ver
que el equipo francés juega muy bien y
es respetuoso con los fans hay árabes
negros blancos amarillos
independientemente de la religión todos
juntos
estamos aquí para celebrar y para dar a
mbappé nuestro apoyo para que en 2026 en
Estados Unidos ganemos
el partido final de la Copa del Mundo
fue visto por más de 24 millones de
personas en el Canal tft de Francia un
récord de audiencia la selección perdió
en penales ante Argentina luego que el
partido terminó igualado a tres goles en
el tiempo reglamentario y la prórroga
los comentaristas franceses han brindado
elogios a la selección al tiempo que
mbappé ha dicho en redes sociales que
Francia volverá mirando el triunfo
dentro de cuatro años en la copa del
mundo que no tendrá uno sino tres países
anfitriones México Estados Unidos y
Canadá